Nếu như một năm thằng sau, tổng thống bí đồ năng trăm tiên bố cách bỏ hợp đồng chính phủ với các công ty của tí phủ
e là nấc, trong khi mất lại công khai ủng hộ việc lận tổng trăm, làm cho mối quan hệ thần thiết giữa hàng người tan vợ ở trên mạc sôi.
Các thằng buồn phát kí ông Trump tại phòng bầu dục chỉ trích ông mất cho rằng cách tiếp kiệm nên xa khảng tí đô là chấm giết chợ cấp và các hợp đồng dành cho tí phủ này.
Ngay sầu đó, cô phíau công ty test là là giúp mối bốn phy bá phân chăm, khiến ra chỉ vốn hóa của công ty vài một chẳng năm mới tí đối là Mỹ,
mất trăm trong ai lớn nhất lix sử, trên mạc sôi ấy, ông mất phản pháo, nhưng mạnh rằng ông Trump
lợp mình trên thằng trong cô bầu cử năm hàng hình phủ trong hàng mới tư và gọi tổng thống lật kể vô hơn.
E là mất quan tuyên bố giúp tổng trụ Dragon, khó trương trình không giản bị ý như một độc thái đáp trạc ở đây giữa tình hả trắng.
Ngọt ngồi một thận bắt đầu từ việc ông mốt công khai phản đối sự lợp các giản phía,
và tăng chi tiêu của chiên quyền. Vợi đây là thảm hỏa đại chính khiến nợ công tăng bầu trong khi đó ông Trump
gạo buộc ông mốt tích dẫn vì mất uống đại phía dành cho sê điện và bị mất bị chi trong chiên quyền.
Chợ đó tí phủ ở lần mốt tình là nhà tại trợ lần nhất cho trên lix sánh cử của tổng thống Trump và lần người đứng đầu bán hiệu qua chiếc vụ.
Tuy nhiên ông mốt đã công khai kêu vợi huy bỏ giúp lần và thậm chí để sức thành lập một đảng chính chị mới.
Đại dịnh số tảm mới cình trong người bị hiệu không ai lòng với cả đảng dân trụ lẫn công hòa.
Cô đánh đầu công khai dựa hãng nhân vật có sức Anh hưởng không chỉ khuyến cộp yếu tất cả lợp.
Mà còn nê dọa quên kiểm soát 2020 của đảng công hòa trong cuộc bầu cử dựa kỳ xác tởi.